sam darnold 2018 his rookie year versus
2019 ended up seven and six after
missing some time with mono passing
yards per game up
touchdowns up interceptions down
expecting to make the big jump this year
and his running back le'veon bell has
one specific piece of advice for the 23
year old quarterback here it is
that sam looks amazing this year no it's
gonna be fun
we just gotta make sure we stay healthy
man i told him i told him no bars
no bars uh very simple but yet very sage
advice from le'veon bell advice that
every nfl player should be heating this
year it was so bizarre last season when
the donald mono case came out of nowhere
right and he was gone for a few weeks
and their backup quarterback position
was disastrous and it set the tone for a
tough season you're throwing a
ridiculously difficult schedule out of
the gates and that grieves the skids for
one and seven but this is a team that's
still finished six and two between them
and the falcons it's amazing to me maybe
it's a covet thing maybe we just i don't
know i don't i don't know why there
isn't more attention on the two teams
that finished the year six and two
because we have accepted in the past as
a given that you can carry that momentum
over into the next year chris and sam
darnold may be carrying that momentum
into 2020 from what he was able to do
once he was back and once he was healthy
last year yeah i mean i would hope so
you know i mean le'veon bell is right
you know the injury the rookie year you
know uh sam darnold had a deal with the
foot injury so we didn't get to see him
in totality that year of course last
year yeah a lot of people got anna
became kind of a running joke up here
right he's in the bars he got you know
mono he must have been kissing girls and
all that type of stuff it kind of became
a funny joke sam darnold's got a great
way about him to me that shows great
leadership by le'veon bell there too you
know the statement he makes right kind
of reassuring sam darnold the team the
offense that like hey sam darnold is a
different guy this year i'm seeing it
you know i hope all you are seeing it
you know players listen to these
comments they're hearing the things
le'veon bell is saying when they're
going home looking on their phone their
ipad the news whatever it is so you know
i think it's between that and then even
taking a nice little jab there you know
no bars this year and making a joke
there that's that's what a great leader
does you know brings out something
that's kind of a inside the locker room
joke and now you know today it causes
some camaraderie in the locker room sam
darnold probably goes over to le'veon
bell and says something like hey you
know how dare you say that or something
with some laughs um but yeah there's
things to be excited about with the new
york jets there is now i don't feel as
excited about them as i do the atlanta
falcons because the atlanta falcons have
been to a super bowl and have an mvp and
have some superstars on their team you
know with the with the jets i do see the
defense the offenses improve they've got
a better offensive line for sure and all
that who are gonna be the guys that make
big plays i guess is the big question i
got that take the pressure off the
offense a little bit that's my big thing
i certainly think they're going to be
better and i think sam darn will be
better year too with adam gases offense
definitely but i just that's my question
with them going here forward
uh control room please mark 752 and 40
seconds am on today's tape what did i
say camaraderie camaraderie
it's always important to have carotery i
think i said the camaraderie
i don't know if that's a form of karate
i don't know carotid artery with your
carotid artery you do karate to the
carotid artery to cause carotery i'm not
sure but i have a feeling we know how
tomorrow's show will be starting here
with yet another addition
to the book of sims isms all right back
to the jets uh look i i
i think sam darnold
with the second year of working with
adam gase yeah remember last year all
the talk about seeing ghosts against the
patriots who doesn't see ghosts against
the patriots rights especially the way
they were playing early last year they
were being compared to the 85 bears
that's right out loud right so i i i
think that there's reason to be
optimistic back to the advice though
that le'veon bell gave to sam daughter
what's the best advice that a veteran
ever gave you other than your dad well
i can remember like as a quarterback
early on in my career like rondae barber
telling me like i mean hey don't be a
quarterback and be like caught at the
club on a wednesday or thursday night
you know that's just stupid and i was
like yeah you're right i mean i'm i got
to be in the first in the you know the
building that day and things like that
so he made me very aware about you know
staying up or staying awake late or
being out late as a quarterback to know
that people are going to use that
against you if you're seeing a dinner at
11 o'clock and you got practice the next
morning or something like that uh so
those are the things but really also i
would say to echo that michael pittman
and rondae barber too like a le'veon
bell
showed they had confidence in me early
in my career to where hey i'll ride with
you sims i know you could be our
starting quarterback things like that
that made me feel like oh wait they're
seeing the work i'm putting in they
realize i'm a different guy out here
this year and that went a long way for
me to when i did become the starter to
go okay i got some guys behind me that
believe in me so let's do this and uh
there's something to be said about that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports